THE SCALE OF ANDROID:
On the surface, Android is the free
open source operating system that runs the world.
Android have over 3 billion active users and over
a 1 billion Android phones are sold every single
year. But, unlike true open source software like
Linux which is run by a non profit foundation,
Android is run by Google, and I’m sure you’ve
figured that this leads to some ulterior motives.
By giving out Android for free, Google is able to
drive billions of users to all of their prominent
products whether that’s Gmail, Google Maps,
Google Search, Google Assistant, Google Drive,
you name it. All of this obviously adds up to
quite a bit of auxiliary revenue but Google also
has much more direct methods of monetizing Android
as well. In fact, it turns out that Android isn’t
actually free at all. Since 2018, Google has been
charging phone makers up to $40 per device.
Technically, this fee isn’t for Android itself
but all of the Google apps that come along with
Android, but let’s be honest, Google apps and
Android are pretty much synonymous at this
point. So phone makers are basically forced
to pay this licensing fee. And let’s not forget
about the crown jewel of Android: the Google Play
Store. The Google Play store generates up to $48
billion in revenue per year over 2/3s of which
has historically been profit. Let me put that in
perspective. You know Windows? The big software
monopoly run by Microsoft that controls 69% of
the desktop market? Well, Windows as a whole only
generated $24.7 billion throughout all of 2022. In
others words, Android generates twice the revenue
of Windows using just the Google Play Store
alone. With that being said, I should mention
that Android also costs Google a lot of money to
maintain. In fact, according to Google’s lawyers,
Google has spent over $40 billion to support
Android over the years. But, with more revenue
than that coming in from just the Play Store every
single year, I suspect that Google is doing just
fine. So, here’s the insane economics of Android
and how much Android is really worth to Google.
DIRECT MONETIZATION:
Starting from the sale of an Android phones,
we have the fee that Google charges Android
phone makers. While this fee can be as much
as $40 per device, the good news is that not
everyone actually pays this much. If you opt
to include minimal Google services on your version
of Android, you can get away with paying as little
as $2.50 per device. But according to Google
themselves, the majority of phonemakers will end
up paying around $20 per device. At this point,
phone makers have been selling over a billion
Android phones every single year for nearly a
decade. So, I think it’s safe to estimate that
Android phones sales alone are pulling in atleast
$20 billion for Google annually, and that’s before
the real monetization even begins. Next up, we
have the Google Play Store. The Apple App Store
tends to garner a lot more media headlines because
they do generate a lot more revenue than the Play
Store. In 2021, they generated $85 billion or
nearly twice the revenue of the Play Store despite
having less than have the users. But, just because
the Apple App Store is more lucrative and takes
all the media heat doesn’t mean that the Play
Store is not lucrative. Google likes to claim that
they have a super developer friendly pricing model
where 97% of developers don’t even have to pay a
fee. But, that’s just because 97% of Play Store
developers don’t make any sort substantial revenue
or they don’t use Google’s payment infrastructure.
When it comes to apps that are actually performing
well and rely on Google’s payment infrastructure
for revenue whether that be paid apps or in app
purchases, the Play Store pretty much has the
exact same pricing model as the Apple App Store.
If your app makes less than $1 million per year,
Apple charges a tax of 15%. And if your app makes
more than $1 million per year, they charge a tax
of 30%. Now, you wanna guess what Google charges?
Well, if your app makes less than $1 million per
year, Google charges 15%, and if your app makes
more than $1 million per year, Google charges 30%.
Google also charges 15% on subscription products
like streaming services and up to 15% on all other
transactions. So, despite being the free open
source OS, Android has the same pricing as the
Apple’s closed private OS. But since iPhone users
are more likely to spend money on apps, Apple
takes all the heat for this pricing model. In the
meantime, Android is quietly racking in as much
as $48 billion per year. A couple of years ago,
in a lawsuit between Oracle and Google, Oracle’s
lawyers estimated that out of the $31 billion in
revenue the Play Store was making at the time,
$22 billion was profit aka 70%. Even if this has
dropped closer to 66%, we’re looking at $32
billion in profit from just the Play Store
alone. For perspective, Google as a whole only
makes $78 billion in profit per year. So, the
Play Store alone might account for as much as 41%
of Google’s entire bottom line. When you combine
this with licensing fees from phone makers, we’re
left with a total of $68 billion worth of direct
revenue from Android or a little over a fifth
of Google’s entire revenue. And all of that is
just from direct monetization. Google’s indirect
monetization efforts are far more interesting.
INDIRECT MONETIZATION:
Given that Google Apps comes preinstalled
on Android devices, billions of users are driven
towards these apps every single year, but I don’t
think you quite realize just how lucrative this
is. Personally, I always assumed that the split
between mobile revenue and desktop revenue was
more or less equal, but it turns out that mobile
is actually far more profitable across the board
especially when it comes to certain apps like
Google Maps. Morgan Stanley estimates that Google
Maps revenue will total $11 billion in 2023 out
of which $9.82 billion or 90% is thanks to mobile
devices. For obvious reasons, Maps is more skewed
towards mobile devices than other Google apps but
trend holds across the board. In fact, over 70% of
YouTube watch time comes from mobile devices and
63% of Google’s search traffic comes from mobile
devices. It’s not just users who prefer mobile
either. It turns out that advertisers also like
to spend a lot more money on mobile ads as 60%
of global digital ad spends comes form mobile
devices. So, there’s no question that controlling
a mobile OS is lucrative, even more lucrative than
controlling a desktop OS, but it’s a lot harder
to quantify this. Thankfully, Google has put on
number on this with their partnership with Apple.
You know how Safari and Siri and other Apple
services direct you to Google search? Well, this
isn’t out of the kindness of their heart or some
sort of affinity for Google. The reality is that
Google actually pays Apple a boatload of money for
Google to be the primary search engine on Apple
devices. $18 billion per year to be precise. And
that’s just for Google search to be the default
search engine. It has nothing to do with Maps or
Photos or Drive or Gmail or Chrome or any of the
other Google services that come preinstalled on
Android devices. Some of these services, people
would likely use regardless of whether it’s
preinstalled or not. For example, people aren’t
gonna switch from Gmail to Outlook just because
the Gmail app does or does not come pre installed.
Similarly, people aren’t gonna switch from YouTube
to DailyMotion just because Android doesn’t come
with YouTube. So, for certain apps, the benefit
of controlling Android is not that large, but for
other apps, it makes all the difference like Maps
for example. When Apple first launched their
own version of Maps in 2012, the vast majority
of iPhone users were extremely disappointed. But
by simply continuing to put it in front of people
and improving the platform, Apple was able to
increase Apple maps usage to be 3 times higher
than Google maps usage on iOS devices by the end
of 2015 itself. So by this point, it’s likely that
80-90% of iPhone users just use Apple maps. So,
Google’s ability to force Google Maps onto Android
users is extremely valuable. Out of the $9.82
billion that Google generates from mobile devices,
likely $7 to $8 billion is directly thanks to
Android. Another instance in which the OS makes
a big difference is cloud storage. Apple hasn’t
released iCloud stats in a while but as of 2018,
they had 850 million iCloud users out of which
170 million were paying. By now, that number is
likely closer to 250 or 300 million paying users.
Each paying user only generates about $2 to $3 in
revenue per month, but at that scale, it adds
up to roughly $8 billion. Now, iCloud is great
and all but it’s likely that most of these users
just use iCloud because it’s already there, it’s
part of the Apple ecosystem, and it works. It’s
likely the same case with Google Photos and Drive
as well. A lot of people who use and pay for those
services likely do it just because it’s already
there, it’s part of the Google ecosystem, and
it works. Combine this with the $18 billion that
Google thinks mobile search is worth and the $7 to
$8 billion from Maps and we’re already up to $34
billion from indirect monetization. We can throw
on more Google services on top of this like Chrome
and Google Assistant and Google Docs and Google
Meet and Google Calendar and we’d probably end up
with something like $50 billion. Combine this with
the $68 billion from their direct monetization
efforts and we’re left with $118 billion in
revenue. To be conservative, we can even call
it $100 billion which brings us into the question
of the day: how much is Android worth to Google?
THE TRUE VALUE OF ANDROID:
Well, keeping things simple, Google
pulls in just under $300 billion worth of revenue
every year and they’re worth $1.67 trillion. So,
given that Android itself conservatively accounts
for $100 billion of this, you could say that
Android is worth $550 billion. That would nearly
make Android a top 10 company by itself. No wonder
Google wanted Android’s founder, Andy Rubin, to be
the next CEO of Google until he got caught up in a
scandal. Android is obviously not the open source
free software that Google likes to position it as,
but honest, putting the insane economics of
Android aside, the true value of Android is
much more than just financial gain. Android
gives Google power over the entire smartphone
experience of over 3 billion people. This gives
them unprecedented access into the innerworkings
of every aspect of these people’s online and
personal lives. What are their interests,
how much money do they make, how does their family
life look like, where do they spend their money,
how do their political beliefs look like, and so
much more that I can never truly list out because
Google takes full advantage of this. Think about
this. Each Android device sends Google 1 MB of
data every 12 hours even when left idle. For
perspective, each iOS devices only sends Apple
52 KB or 1/20th of the data every 12 hours. This
means that Android collects 2 MB of data every
day from every Android user even if they’re not
actively using their phones. From the entire 3.3
billion Android user base, that translates to 6.6
Petabytes of data every single day or 2.4 Exabytes
of data every single year. Google likes to assert
that this does not accurately depict their data
collection efforts because a lot of this data is
just software updates and device status related
things. But just because a lot of it is harmless
doesn’t mean that all of it is, and considering
that Google’s entire business model is collecting
data and showing ads, it’s likely that a good
amount of is more than what you’d be comfortable
sharing. Things like the location data,
search history, phone usage, online purchases, and
even biometrics of 3.3 billion people, and that
is the real power of Android. The $100 billion in
revenue from Android is really just a bonus. With
historically high interest rates, the appeal bills
and bonds is the higher than ever, yet traditional
brokerages haven’t really adapted with the times.
They still expect people to use clunky bond
tables, scroll through long overwhleming lists,
and even use virtual keyboards till recently.
And that’s why we created our own modern bond
platform: Silo. At Silo, we prioritize the user
experience and the ease of finding and investing
in the issuers you know and trust, so that you
too can lock in high yields. Also, choosing a
strong user experience doesn’t mean sacrificing
on safety. Every Silo account is insured by
$500,000 in SIPC insurance and $2.5 million
in FDIC insurance. Also, all funds deposited on
the platform will be maintained by our trusted
custodian, Interactive Brokers, who has experience
managing $373 billion worth of assets over the
past 45 years. So, if you’re looking for a modern
way to invest in bonds, please consider checking
out Silo in the description below. Not all is
well with the Android empire though. In fact,
they’ve been slowly bleeding market share to Apple
for years now. Check out this video to learn more.